over the past hundred years no other
natural disaster in the U.S has caused
more death and destruction than floods
they can happen any place any day
anytime and they will likely only get
worse
as people cluster around coastal regions
and floodplains our growing population
will confront the awesome power of water
for thousands of years Farmers have
depended on seasonal floods
the waters irrigated their crops and
fertilized their lands
today excess water is channeled into
reservoirs and power hydroelectric dams
but when water levels rise suddenly far
more than the ground can absorb a flood
occurs
flash floods are a perfect example
sudden storms unleash a torrential
downpour
the runoff moves with surprising Force
at a depth of two feet the water can
push aside a car
in fact half of all deaths from flash
floods involve vehicles
but floods occur in many other ways
heavy rains and fine snowfall can
overwhelm Rivers
Storm surges caused by hurricanes and
tsunamis inundate the coastline
landslides and mud flows can displace
large volumes of water dams break levees
fail
great Mississippi flood of 1993
several of these factors came into play
over ten thousand square miles of the
midwestern United States were
overwhelmed with rain
in a cruel twist the Earthen dams known
as levees along the Upper Mississippi
river forced the water to flow
Downstream faster and stronger
communities further down river were hit
with the full brunt of the Mississippi
two-thirds of all the levees were
breached
though towns rallied to protect their
lives and livelihoods the damage was
still immense
over 10 billion dollars in Damages
56 000 homes flooded or destroyed and
some 50 people were killed
at the start of this Century another
powerful flood wreaked havoc this one
coming from the sea
Storm surges of Hurricane Katrina
submerged 80 percent of the City of New
Orleans
over 1800 people died in the floods
the damage has been estimated at over 80
billion dollars
in some ways the New Orleans disaster
was unique much of the city lies below
sea level
and despite years of warning the city
was woefully unprepared to handle a
breach of the levees which kept it dry
but we are still vulnerable
sea levels May rise
coastlines could erode
rain patterns might change
snowpacks could melt
and then the waters would rush in